hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Gotham episode 7 video some of the
best Riddler scenes I think we've gotten
all season long so just careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the episode
yet towards the end of season 1 they
were teasing like a really strong
Riddler arc and now we're really
starting to see the fruits of that like
we're slowly getting towards full-blown
Riddler costume but the actor that plays
Riddler was talking about the next
version of his costume it's gonna be
green but we're not gonna see any
question marks on it but we will see him
dropping more riddles and I don't know
if we've seen the last of the shadow
self like the shadow Riddler but let's
just go ahead and do top five WTF
there's a whole bunch of storylines that
we need to talk about starting with
number 5
Catwoman versus silver st. cloud this is
your standard Mean Girls storyline I
think we're all just looking forward to
Catwoman clawing Silver's eyes out as
far as story arcs go like I always enjoy
seeing Catwoman Bruce arcs but I feel
like this is gonna be one of the less
interesting ones on the show like like
the Riddler
Gordon versus Theo those are gonna be a
little bit more thrilling Catwoman vs.
silver st. cloud is more of like a
schoolyard fight situation unless
Catwoman breaks out her shotgun and
shoots silver in the chest that would be
pretty crazy if Riddler can walk around
with a severed hand then surely Catwoman
can start using that shotgun on some
people but the big problem right now I
think is with Bruce's character he is
now one of the dumbest characters on the
show like Gordon finally figured out
what was going on with Theo like he
finally like woke up the light bulb turn
on his head
that has not happened for Bruce yet or
he's choosing to ignore the warning
signs just because he's so desperate for
companions silver said I'm going to be
Bruce's only friend you know like trying
trying to get Catwoman to go away imply
that if Catwoman didn't stop hanging out
with Bruce she was gonna have her killed
and part of me feels like Bruce actually
believes that like his self-esteem is so
low that like if you told him you don't
have any friends part of him would
believe it when he actually does have
quite a bit of friends at Gordon's his
friend
Alfred's his friend Catwoman's his
friend eventually he'll realize that but
I think it's gonna be Catwoman that's
gonna take care of silver just because
their conflict is a little bit more
physical I don't see Bruce doing a whole
lot of punching and kicking until Ezreal
comes on the show and I really don't
even know what they're gonna do with
that character it's the order of st.
Dumas that's the big group of people
that's coming to town Azrael is just
part of that and actually just to clear
I saw some people on my last coughing
video asking whether or not this is a
quarter valve storyline or this is an
Azrael storyline actually it's neither
it will eventually turn into a quarter
valve storyline but the court are those
original ruling families of Gotham that
kicked the duma out the duma family that
became the gala bands is represented by
the order of st. Dumas that's actually a
larger organization that the Dumas
family just kind of integrated into and
co-opted so the first half of this
family is more about the revenge of the
Dumas family and then I think the court
of Alice will rear its head in response
it's like if you have a club you kick
someone out then that person comes back
with another organization to try and
take over the original club will
eventually answer in kind with force now
obviously we just we haven't seen the
rest of those families yet we've only
seen the Wayne's and we've only seen the
Duma there are other families that will
eventually meet so I'm the number four
Theo
versus Bruce has the explain Theo's
gonna try and take Wayne Enterprises
from Bruce take control it's a little
bit like what Bane did to Batman during
the Dark Knight Rises to you know take
that big cushion away although in the
Dark Knight Rises Batman had already
spent most of his wealth so he kind of
already pulled the rug out from under
himself but you get the idea feel slowly
trying to take Bruce's agency as well as
his sense of self away from him so he's
waging a physical a psychological and an
economic war against the Wayne family
speaking of physical war on to number
three penguin versus Theo and now butch
the butch part is a little bit more fun
but with the whole reason for them
killing penguins mother I think is
twofold
one to galvanize penguin against Theo
two just to show who the real villain on
the show is so that penguin even though
he's super evil becomes an antihero at a
certain point into I just I don't think
they knew what to do with the character
going forward they they didn't have a
compelling arc for her of all the
characters in and around penguin in the
comics his mother isn't a really big
figure so there's just not that many
directions to take his mother on the
show so she has to go this is just the
most efficient way for the writers to
get rid of her like well throw her under
the bus
but in doing so will push penguin over
the edge so penguins as declared war on
Theo and everyone around him which is
now butch although technically butch is
his own man
he says I think he's being honest when
he says that penguin was controlling him
like a marionette so now butch doesn't
have to act like a puppet so much like
there were points last year when he
literally acted like a puppet he danced
like a puppet so I'm kind of glad that
that's over even though Theo versus
Gotham is all about his war against the
Wayne family I do think that penguin is
gonna be the one to ultimately take Theo
down so like deliver the killing blow
spin which on the number two
Gordon versus Theo Gordon officially
declares war on Theo to his face that
the light bulb finally comes on in his
head in this episode I was wondering how
long it would take him early in the
episode tigress was complaining about
how she wasn't getting to have any fun
when are you gonna let me have some fun
Theo well this is just the signal that
fun will be had there will be open war
in the streets like we're moving towards
the mid-season finale big battles and in
order for that to happen you have to
have this this open villain moment where
Theo's like you're coming after me well
good luck you could try but you're not
going to succeed so now the line in the
sand has been drawn you have like Gordon
coming at Theo from one direction you
have penguin coming from in another
direction you have Theo coming it brews
from two different directions
everybody's getting ready to start
slinging bullets in the order of st.
Dumas hasn't even got here yet but
finally under my favorite storyline this
week the Riddler versus himself so if he
ever watched Joss Whedon's Buffy or
angel angel had this like this internal
war going on in himself where there was
the Angelus self the evil version of
himself that didn't have a soul and then
there was the angel character like the
good character that did have a soul so
the Riddler here has his own version of
that only the Angelus version of himself
wins so he cracks a smile and just
starts dicing this kringles body up I
was actually surprised that she was dead
I actually I had to check the wiki after
last week and it was like Miss Kringle
gravely injured so I was like maybe
she's not dead but then sure enough the
minute that severed hand showed up in
this episode in the vending machine no
less I was like yep definitely dead
definitely definitely dead that was one
of the best parts to you know better
than the smile of the end was him
finding the hand in the vending machine
who else thought the rest of her was
hidden behind other vending machine
slots like he'd have to start hitting
like all the buttons just to get it out
we're gonna need a shitload of dollar
bills to get her out of there that'd be
like the cartoon version of Gotham let
me know in the comments though what was
your favorite part about the episode and
who do you think is going to be the one
to kill
Theo ultimately or do you think that
he's just gonna get away do you think
it's gonna be like fish Mooney and we
won't see like a severed head or a body
james frain is such a good actor I'd be
really sad at the show lost him forever
so hopefully like they'll find some way
to explain him getting away like you do
want to see the penguin twist the blade
inside them just just to get a little
bit of revenge but you don't want to see
the show lose the character forever well
what's gonna happen next is is
Constantine is coming on arrow it's
gonna be badass it's also a big Black
Canary episode too so be sure to watch
it on TV when it airs even if you've
already watched the episode everybody's
like winking at each other so I'll post
that video later tonight after the
episode airs but agent of shield also
just revealed the identity of lash so
I'll post that video Thursday and then
I'm working on a Supergirl video that'll
post later on Thursday hopefully I'll
have a room tour video sometime soon -
I'm having a bunch of furniture
delivered so it should actually look
like a real person's apartment that
someone lives in and not just a bunch of
bear rooms with like my recording space
so be sure to subscribe to get
everything and if you guys didn't see my
Warcraft video the full trailer for that
is coming on Friday I'm doing a special
giveaway for it so just watch my
Warcraft teaser video if you don't know
what's going on with that well you guys
wait for everything to post you can
click here for that that warcraft teaser
video if you haven't seen it yet and you
can click here for last night's episode
- the flash probably one of the best
episodes this season thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight
you